رحبت جنوب افريقيا بالاجراءات المؤقته
التي فرضتها محكمه العدل الدوليه على
اسرائيل ووصفت الحكم بالانتصار الحاسم
لسياده القانون وبالمنع طف المهم في البحث
عن العداله للشعب الفلسطيني ولكن في الوقت
نفسه ود البلد الافريقي لو ان المحكمه
اصدرت حكما اكثر حزما بوقف فوري لاطلاق
النار في
[موسيقى]
غزه تصريحات ن ليدي باندور وزيره العلاقات
الدوليه والتعاون في جنوب افريقيا اعادت
الى الاذهان امرا اصدرته المحكمه قبل نحو
عامين عن الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ويظهر تباين القرارات عندما يتعلق الامر
باسرائيل ففي القرار الاخير الذي صدر في
اعقاب الدعوه التي رفعتها جنوب افريقيا
على دوله الاحتلال طالبت المحكمه اسرائيل
باتخاذ جميع الاجراءات التي في وسعها لمنع
ارتكاب جميع الافعال ضمن نطاق الماده
الثانيه من اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه
واكدت ان عليها الالتزام بتجنب كل ما
يتعلق بالقتل والاعتداء والتدمير لسكان
غزه وان تضمن توفير الاحتياجات الانسانيه
الملحه في القطاع فورا لكن قبل عامين
وتحديدا في مارس اذار
2022 بتت محكمه العدل الدوليه في دعوه
قضائيه مشابهه رفعتها اوكرانيا على روسيا
بعد شهر واحد من اندلاع الحرب اتهمت كيف
فيها موسكو بخرق اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه
واصدرت المحكمه قرارا امرت فيه روسيا
بتعليق عملياتها العسكريه التي بداتها في
اوكرانيا على الفور موقف المحكمه من من
القضيتين اظهر تباينا في حده القرارين
الصادرين علما ان اعداد القتلى في
اوكرانيا بعد عامين من الحرب كان وفقا
لتقرير نشرته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه اقل من ضعف عدد النساء والاطفال
الذين استشهد في غزه خلال شهرين ونصف
الشهر فقط تباين الموقف يذكر بدعوه قضائيه
بتت فيها المحكمه عام 2002 في بلجيكا كان
قد رفعها 23 فلسطينيا ولبناني ممن نجوا من
مذبحه صبره وشاتيلا على اري اي شارون رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق اتهموه فيها
بارتكاب جرائم حرب بحق الانسانيه واعمال
اباده جماعيه لكن المحكمه اصدرت قرارا
بانه لا يحق لبلجيكا محاكمه شارون ما دام
في منصبه ويتمتع بحصانه دبلوماسيه وهو ما
دفع اسرائيل حينها الى الترحيب
بالقرار
n